[Musique]
ma rencontre avec cyril elle et elle
date de il ya longtemps
donc après on va voir que je suis
vieille donc je vais pas dire depuis
quand en fait on se rencontrait il ya
dans une quinzaine d'années quelqu'un
zoé 15 16 ans tueur un court de tennis
il parlait même sur les camps des tennis
quand il joue il parle soul gamme
ma rencontre avec cyril elle a été très
flippant moi je faisais de l'antenne moi
j'ai été au chien d'amour au firmament
de du mec live que je sortais loft et
c'était pendant un break entre deux
prises de parole et j'ai vu un garçon
qui évidemment déjà faisait le mariole
essayé avant de percer dans ce petit
tailleur qu'il était à peine stagiaires
ou un truc comme ça sert évidement il
m'a impressionné vation en fait sans le
connaître pour moi c'est le roi du pape
mais bah non c'est une saloperie dans la
presse à propos de mes blouson en cuir
prada en disant que je suis plus qui m'a
bel ibère trucs horribles fabrique dont
seule série des ailes secret j'étais à
côté de lui on avait un tournoi en
parallèle je me souviens tout à fait de
lui autour d'un bol de chips enfin un
énorme bol de chips n'était en face de
lui j'étais hyper stressée hyper gêné et
a commencé à prendre le bol de chips à
danser avec ce fameux bol de chips à
aller jeter partout s'étaient croisés en
boîte de nuit et je crois qu'on s'était
un peu accroché on s'en remet comme ça
ce type là est soit un grand malade soit
en génie et on a commencé à parler a
sympathisé
puisque tu admires o'conner il m'a dit
des clubs portent des blousons ben moi
chier gros coup voilà il a ce don il a
cette force de mettre à l'aise donc du
coup je me suis très vite intégré ça
c'était la première rencontre sportive
c'était assez d assez viril venir j'irai
flippante
je m'aperçois qu'ils viennent
[Musique]